the other idea
about nietzsche is uh on his idea of
morality
he presents the argument that uh
morality is a
human illusion and that uh you know
there's not
such a thing as good and evil these are
all kind of constructs
do you think there's such a thing as a
good and evil that's connected to some
objective reality
i think that there are some i
actually do believe that there are some
universals i'm not kantian in any way
but i do think that there are some
universals and
the thing that actually brought me to
even the concept of that was jung
so you know jung's concept of the
collective unconsciousness
and then taking that thought and then
applying it to looking through his
history and uh the most varied history
you can find
so i would say probably religion is your
earliest one
that you can get for for written history
or uh
written examples of human behavior and
psychology
at its at the the furthest that we can
look into it
uh with you know from man's hand to
whatever the medium is uniform or
whatever but as you do that and then
let's say going
from mesopotamia to india to
you know europe to and just going from
all these places as disparate as they
may seem
as many different cultures and
ethnicities and religions and how the
religions will
vary quite a bit from monotheists to uh
polytheist and so on and so forth but
then just seeing how there's all the
through lines and
of course campbell he did this uh much
earlier than
me thinking about it but uh i think that
by
looking at things that way and starting
to find the threads instead of always
just looking at everything as being its
own compartmentalized
concept as if it only applies to this
time this people like getting
overly pomo about it is just a really
idiotic post-modern
so you think that there is uh just like
joseph campbell there's a thread that
connects
all of these stories narratives that we
constructed for ourselves as we evolve
and that thread is grounded in some kind
of
absolute ideas of maybe on the morality
side which is the trickiest one of good
and evil
somewhat yeah i think that a lot of this
stuff is just derived from a biological
perspective i feel like these things are
innate within us
do you think our innately humans are
good like we
no i don't i feel like
i also feel like there's an issue of
scale too like
um like nasim taleb likes to talk about
how he
views his the way he interacts with with
groups
in terms of scale you know what is this
thing about like at uh
at the familia level i'm a i'm a
communist and then at the
civic level i'm a i'm a republican or
something
at this other level then it goes on at
the widest level he's a libertarian or
something of that
nature you know like fundamentally human
interaction changes
on scale on scale and scale and also uh
from
uh you know subjective to the
environment around them so
and i don't even mean environment just
in the sake of physical environment uh
nature right like nature is constantly
trying to murder you well it's not
really trying it's just
nature's being nature the universe is
the universe and
uh at times it takes you out it's just
not with any particular uh compunction
or prejudice it's just oops you know
sorry there's no more dodos
my bad but don't you think the
particular flavor of the complexity
that is the human mind was created like
let me make an argument for that all
people are fundamentally good
okay is uh there's an evolutionary
advantage
to being to striving to uh cooperate
to add more love to the world of like
compassion empathy all that kind of
stuff
and that the very thing that created
the human mind was
this evolutionary advantage whatever the
forces behind this evolutionary
advantage
and scale yes so when we're dealing with
a small tribe
sure yeah when you meet another tribe
maybe there are other factors that are
going into that
let's say you scale up and so
your 150 has exceeded their 150 and
like you start to get to a certain point
where
um you can't really be
close enough to someone down the line of
some of
that next like that 150s 150 150 and
they just now all of a sudden become
some some guy whatever and when it comes
to some guy
at once it starts hitting scale i don't
know that it's
capable people can be
as as magnanimous to a stranger as
to the known if they orient themselves
to be
secure enough because it does come to
security insecurity
in one way or the other either brought
on by the unknown brought on by
an actual threat brought on by even
their own as we would use the word
insecurity
in that their own insecurity within
their own capabilities their own belief
in themselves
all these things um can change things
from
being compassionate and what have you to
at least at the very least
maybe not evil but self-interest driven
to the point of
negative results for those that aren't
you know what i mean right
but another way to frame that is uh
maybe
it's less about scale and more about the
amount of resources available so
if we're overflowing with resources in
terms of
uh security and safety all the
things you've mentioned if we have more
than enough resources then the way we
treat a stranger
the way we position ourselves towards
that stranger might be
in a way that uh allows us to be our
real human selves as opposed to sort of
our animal self
and therefore it's mostly about how
clever can we
descendants of abes be in coming up with
all cool kinds of technologies and ways
to uh
efficiently use the resources we have
such that we're not constrained
and my hope is that we can
that human innovation will outpace
the growth of our the number of people
that are starving for resources
yes uh i think that there's a lot of uh
rationality behind
uh this argument and
you know in in some ways i agree and and
in a lot of ways i see it as
missing the point of of how this
experiment has
has been playing out across time when
you look at uh what
what for one it's like defined resources
you know what is a what is a resource of
of
as humans uh would define it right
or wealth even and so you can say
well you know an iphone's a resource the
internet's a resource
uh water obviously is a resource but if
we
weigh them what is more important to
human beings
water internet or iphones it's water
right so if we look at resources if we
start with
what do human beings need to live i mean
actually live not live here in
this fantasy creation extension
of our own
ingenuity and you know a prison of our
own creation and also a paradise of our
own creation
but this is not how human beings
normally live this is all built upon
stuff
on on this built on concept on idea
and some and and some of it's built on
just well this is the paradigm so this
is what you do
human beings need food they need water
to survive
they need shelter from the elements and
they need certain skills
to perpetuate these things and be able
to pass them down so that they can
so these things don't become uh
you don't end up in this this gap where
you have to relearn things
because if it's lost then
that time before you can get it back
again is going to be
a dark ages of sorts you know or it's
going to be highly detrimental to
to your group because not knowing how to
fish
not knowing how to hunt not knowing how
to even
clean and cook the game once you have it
could be lethal that's fascinating to
think of that as a basic resource the
knowledge to attain the very
low level things of water right and
we'll figure it out we did it once
before
and we've done it over and over and over
and over again it's just costly
yes it has costs for sure um
but when you think of how
you look at the well we'll just deal
with
the first world of the west you look at
the the
the path line the pathway of of western
civilization
and its growth and then you look at how
technology injected into it over time
you know how it magnifies uh
things or pushes things at uh orders of
magnitude faster
and then the internet comes along and
even faster you know so you're watching
industrial revolution to
what is it the uh the capacitor and then
so on it goes further and further and as
the internet and technology
especially on the electronic side of
things start increasing in capability
it massively outpaces even our
uh necessity for it at times it becomes
you know
plan obsolescence happens quicker and
over and over and over again
and wealth increases increases increase
increases
in terms of the things that we're able
to acquire right i mean you i've seen
homeless people with
with smartphones you know so we're
living in the most
wealth-laden luxury-laden age of
all of humanity yet what happens when
we see calamity or people go on hard
time what are
they the things that they value you know
what what is what do people go to an
argument about the cost of things that
are luxury items generally
and not necessity items you know we get
into fights
about um you know things that are
at the end of the day not necessities to
us you know people are so concerned
about
netflix and and the internet and
personally i'm very concerned about the
internet
because i look at it as my own little
personal library of alexandria
in my pocket that's what i love about it
and the ability to
have a tool as effective as it is even
though i'm in a constant battle
to not let that tool become a vice
or to become something that that
actually
brings me to a lower state but we will
the question is
over the are we willing to murder each
other over netflix
versus murder each other over water
we're willing to murder each other over
water
that's a given right but that's our
animalistic selves of that well it's
also a necessity for
it's animalistic but it's also either
you do it or you don't right like unless
somebody's willing to share that water
or if that water is of such a limited
uh uh capability or such a limited
amount
then you will have to murder right to
have that one netflix the argument is
the higher
we get up to this hierarchy of what we
consider
in los angeles resources yes we're less
willing to be
to commit violence we're less willing to
commit violence the oh
i would say over netflix but we are
willing to commit violence over netflix
over everything associated with netflix
over
televisions over sneakers over over
um you know i mean when we look at a
good
i mean the majority of the stuff that
came with the riots i mean it was
use car dealerships uh targets
i mean and then you look it's like whoa
okay well what are people
what do they gotta what are they so
hell-bent to get
out of this whole thing i'm even talking
about the ideological elements or
anything like that just like okay
something's going on boom looting
whatever
yeah we you know there's stuff what are
you gonna loot yeah you know you'll have
aoc say oh people needing bread
like i didn't see a single loaf of bread
you know i saw
televisions poetry you know but
to me it is poetry in a sense because
you get to see
who we how we actually are operating you
know
what are where what is becoming first
principles to most people but
wait wait but you could also argue that
those rides were more like the madness
of crowds which is
definitely a lot more than just that i'm
just saying that given a chance it's
like okay
boom the the lights are off the grid is
down
we've we've hacked into the whole system
it's turned into an 80s movie and
you have the ability to go get a hold of
whatever it is that you think is most
important and what do we do
and i say we as in you know including
all of us we grab a tv
we we attack it we we we break into a
sneaker store on melrose we do it's just
like
we still giant cause statues or
the value of that is completely market
driven like
it's just a piece of polypropylene or
whatever butyl
and you know it's cool you know i'm a
big fan of art uh but uh
it's like you know i can't eat that and
at the end of the day man
you're sitting there with your with your
like what'd you do today honey what'd
you get you know man
we were able to you know oh i got this i
got this designer art statue
are you gonna go well you can't really
sell it on the on like the art markets
where people are really gonna pay for it
so
are you gonna become an underground art
dealer with your one piece of cause
art
you